في واحد صوب صب في واحد صوب في واحد صوب
مين مينم رجعوا رجعوا رجعوا رجعوا الشباب
رجعوا الشباب في واحد صوب مستشفى اللي
قبالك هذه مستشفى التركي القناصه عليها
بتطخ على الشباب حملوا واحد ه حملوا واحد
حملوا واحد هيين بيجروا فيه اصابه في رجله
اصابه في رجله هي كمان طلق فيهم وقع وقع
وقع وقع وقع وقع وقع وقع كمان
واحد تعال
تعال احكي ايش اللي صار معكم اخ اخوي عبد
الله عبد الله ععد طبازه اشرشر معكم على
السريع كنا نمشي نمشي وطوره من هنا اقيت
هوق غاد ولا اج معاكم اه استشهد قلبه
استشهد على المطره استشهد ده ايش اسمه
الله يرحمه عبد الله عدنان احمد تواز
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل لا انتوا كم واحد
كنتوا خمسه خمسه اه جوع الى غزه
ها طخ
علينا طخ علينا
طخ
[تصفيق]
علينا شباب اقفوا اقفوا اقفوا
وا طلاق علينا
مباشره